and now time for the uplift at eight
where we share stories that we bring
some joy to your day vlad what do you
got for us so uh this is a little bit of
a baby announcement it's gonna melt your
heart melissa damaris is expecting her
first child but her best friend andrea
cavallari had her own news to check out
listen to this
oh it's so cute it's you right it's
supposed to go this way like drinking
and then bites drinking buggies
[Music]
so let me explain what's going on here
melissa could hardly believe it when her
best friend andrea announced that she is
also expecting with the help of those
two little onesies she thought that
like maybe i thought she was having
twins
yeah i thought it was a mistake when she
gave me two i really wasn't expecting it
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
so both are expecting boys and their due
dates are just 11 weeks apart melissa in
august andrea in mid-october and they
hope the little boys just like their
moms will be best friends
oh well you know i got one better than
that okay uh now
i announced my firstborn was coming and
literally my girlfriend says she's four
weeks now uh
guess what i think maybe i might be we
went out and got a pregnancy test and
boom she was so and now are your kids
friends they are friends live in
different places but karen horton just
gotta say that's gotta be a little bit
right we're having a kid and your best
friend has a kid and then yeah yeah
that's right why don't we see guy videos
like that like hey dude you guys could
care less hey dude our videos are like
hey it has like uh there's no cute like
onesie passing on us now our videos are
like step brothers where we're like hey
i like dinosaurs you like dinosaurs yeah
sorry i just became best having a baby
all right man
good job bladdy whacky all right